hello and welcome to the point the final
episode of the point actually as I leave
GameSpot at the end of this week so no
better time than to shoot an episode I
have been dying to do since we started
this show if you're a fan of the show
you know I love talking about virtual
worlds and their real-world counterparts
so a few weeks ago and I was sent on a
press trip to New York I knew it was the
perfect opportunity to shoot something
fun you see if I've never actually been
to New York before but as somebody who's
played countless areas of Grand Theft
Auto three and four
I feel like I know the place so let's
put that to the test this week on the
point I go all Anthony Bourdain as I
attempt to explore the real world
version of grand theft auto's Liberty
City without murdering a single
prostitute
[Music]
before we hit the road a quick geography
lesson Liberty City is based on New York
and more specifically four of its five
boroughs the central island of Manhattan
is known as Algonquin in the game
Brooklyn to its East is known as broker
to the north of that lies the borough of
Queens
aka dukes while to the north of that the
island of Bohannon the game takes the
place of the Bronx a sprawling
neighborhood that in real life is to the
north of Manhattan the fifth borough in
real life at least is Staten Island but
this isn't really in GTA 3 or 4 Staunton
island which appears in GTA 3 takes the
name but was really just an extension of
Manhattan the fifth borough used in
grand theft auto 4 is alderney which is
actually a facility of New Jersey the
state that lies across the Hudson River
to the west so while I flew in to Jersey
City on today's adventure I'm gonna be
focusing my trip on manhattan brooklyn
and queens
as most of the games action takes place
in those boroughs the thing is I only
have 12 hours to see the city before my
next work appointment and I've got a
checklist of things I want to see and do
grab a hot dog and star junction see
happiness island play bowling with my
cousin on the ho beach boardwalk and
grab some beers with an old friend in
the Steinway beer garden so as bright
and early as I could possibly muster I
crawled out of bed packed the cameras
and started filming good morning friends
and welcome to New York City Oh for the
sake of today's exercise Liberty City
this is the Lower East Side of Manhattan
and quite an arty district and it's
actually a pretty good launch point to
start off today's adventures because
before I head east to Brooklyn and Coney
Island and all that which is kind of
where I want to show off first because
it's where I have thought of for
starters I want to head slightly to the
west of here because I only a couple of
blocks from the two parts of I guess New
York which prominently feature in Grand
Theft Auto 3 which are a little Italy
and Chinatown I've heard that they're
actually really really close to each
other like they're barely separated by a
block at all so before I head down to
Coney Island and try get some bowling in
let's jump over there and see if we
I don't know eat some pizza and get some
ramen first things first I take a short
walk from my hotel and end up in
Chinatown and neighborhoods so popular
in the series that it even got its own
game on surprising really considering
it's about a 15-minute walk from
rockstars New York headquarters on
Broadway I've been to China towns in the
past I lived in London and San Francisco
and you know they all kind of look the
same but there is something uniquely
Liberty City about this one probably
something to do it'd be you know yellow
cabs and the fire escapes and the sounds
of police sirens clunk off every five
seconds but the other thing that comes
across here which doesn't at all in the
games is the smell there's smells here
are incredible every five feet that's
something new it's one second it's boba
tea the next is barbecue pork the next
isn't nail salon then you've got some
raw fish they probably something is the
fact that I have my breakfast yet but I
shouldn't have any trouble finding
somewhere because right next door to
Chinatown in fact I seem to have
accidentally just walked into Little
Italy
[Music]
well I'll just have like a three-course
meal for breakfast which probably Boston
idea but I do color walking today so
hopefully I should be okay and yeah
Little Italy very reminiscent of grand
theft auto 3 at the one thing I will say
that the games were missing which was
very prominent here was tourists it's
the double-edged sword of any place that
becomes notorious is that instantly then
people try and cash in on that notoriety
and I mean you can tell that like there
is an Italian community there like you
can tell there is a Chinese community in
Chinatown but you know there's also a
lot of people that want to buy some
t-shirts and you know talk to the
restaurant dude who kind of looks a
little bit like Ray Liotta another grab
that thought a reference there actually
but I getting out of the city for now
I'm gonna head down to where I cried a
little for starts off and Coney Island
which is a better 50 minute subway ride
from here so I'm gonna do something that
you basically never do when you play the
Grand Theft Auto games I'm gonna use
public transport Max Payne the darkness
the division GTA there's no shortage of
games that have oKed the particular
muggy darkness of the New York subway
system
my first trip on its trains took me
across the Manhattan Bridge and sassed
towards broker into the Russian area of
Brighton Beach I knew this was more than
likely the spot that they based Romans
apartment in but I had no idea what I
was about to witness when I got off the
train
holy I just yeah basically outside
Roman and eco spice here I just walked
out of the Brighton Beach subway station
Boynton Beach Auto beach in GTA anyone
who knows said the thing that knows
brighton and hove are basically two
towns stuck together and so obvious
connection there
and yet this is like straight this is
like I just walked out into the start of
Grand Theft Auto 4 super like Eastern
European influence all the stores right
here loads of stuff written in Cyrillic
this whole situation basically on the
way they answer to the beach so they're
not adjacent to each other like the iron
the game so I'm gonna walk down a bit
until I hit the water and then try and
make it to the boardwalk and see if
there's any and any bowling out
my ring my cousin yeah sheep we can get
a game in just like GTA the folks in
Brighton Beach spoke Russian as a first
language but it didn't have time to sit
and chat the walk to Coney Island is
actually a good 30 minutes even though
they are directly adjacent to each other
in the game but regardless of the scale
the accuracy of this whole area is
eye-opening there's a huge wooden roller
coaster the ramp to the boardwalk is
almost identical the wood the handrails
alcoves the pier the big wheel it's all
here just suffering from the same
tourism problem I witnessed in Chinatown
and Little Italy in fact this whole
experience has made me think maybe GTA 4
is set during the winter anyway I was
here for a reason to play bowling with
my cousin but without any actual cousins
in Liberty City I call the next best
thing
gamespot usergroups you riot who lives
just a few miles east of you while in
the game the bowling alley is right on
the boardwalk in real life the actual
bowling alley is just one block north
using my GPS I made my way through the
packs of tourists but just as I thought
I'd found it in keeping with bowling
alley tradition the Brio bowling alley
has been shut down but that wasn't gonna
stop us we took an uber to the nearest
alternative and hit the lanes
[Music]
take that you son of a after an
hour of random bowling I said farewell
to cousin goob and made my way back to
Manhattan first on the list it was a
boat ride around Happiness Island rather
confusingly known as Liberty Island in
the game and though the boat was more
concerned at making sure all the
tourists got Mike's photographs of
Manhattan and Lady Liberty in true GTA
tourist fashion I got distracted by
something nobody else on the boat seemed
to notice so I just got off the ferry to
happiness Island during its Liberty
Island as it's known around these parts
and one of the coolest things that
happened was right when we were leaving
Manhattan I could hear the sound of this
like nostalgic like no way kind of
feeling when that happened so I look
over the side of the boat where I think
it is and sure enough there is a helipad
like heliport with a helicopter on us
and taking off but immediately I was
thinking oh man I need to jump off this
boat swim over there steal a helicopter
and do a proper tour of New York City
but yeah it's just one of the many times
that I've been walking around and
thought oh I think this is here and then
orientated myself and sure enough what
was right there so although the scale is
completely different although everything
is like much much further apart the like
angle and orientation everything
more often than not is is pretty
accurate and that's been very surprising
so before I head north of towards
Midtown I'm gonna drop in on the 9/11
memorial obviously the September 11th
attacks happened right around the time
the grand theft auto 3 kidnap and they
had to sort of reorient get that game
back in and and change some elements to
make sure that they weren't offending
anyone and so none of that stuff is in
in the game and I'm pretty sure GTA 4
doesn't do anything to do with it either
I'm not gonna film down there just out
of respect for the victims and the site
what people tell me it's a lovely place
to go so I'm looking looking forward to
taking my respects after an incredibly
moving visit to the 9/11 memorial at
once again descended into the net
familiar subway system I took the train
to Times Square known as Starr junction
in GTA this is not only the de-facto
center of the map in GTA 4 it's also
where a bunch of missions and slide
activities take place from going to see
Katt Williams and Ricky Gervais is in
the local comedy club to multiplayer GTA
race battles up and down its various
promenade as expected the real world
version was far bigger but the sense of
scale feels about the same GTA 4 does
this wonderful fisheye thing whenever
you turned the camera upwards towards
the sky looking up in Times Square feels
very similar this might be the most real
part of the whole trip actually because
between like GTA races and just general
messing around in the single-player I
probably spend more time here than
anywhere else and like dude doing this
figure of 8 races around the park and a
bus in the middle and just watching
everyone crash into it and generally
just like murdering people and crashing
cars and stuff oddly enough one of the
weirdest parts about being here is that
all of the screens are advertising real
products just something that like stood
out to me
goes to show how realistic that world in
gta4 is and this one almost feels like
an impostor like like GTA was the real
one and then they built this like theme
park version of Times Square
sort of people get visited or just weird
I was like me you travel to New York so
they could have a Grand Theft Auto for
trip down memory lane okay so if my
personal knowledge of this area is right
from the video games that's such a proc
should be just north here I'm gonna
attempt to walk up there see if it's
there but first I need to get some
Street time was ticking away so I had to
keep moving Street meat in hand I made
my way north towards what's known as
Middle Park in GTA 4
sure enough though the walk was longer
than the Liberty City equivalent I did
eventually arrive at the southern wall
of Central Park Middle Park is vast in
real life but has the same sort of Oasis
in a concrete world feel of the game or
skyscrapers peak attitude from behind
leaves a quiet spot full of Lakes areas
for children to play and plenty of open
spaces a place where joggers families
and the destitute share common ground
but sadly I couldn't stay to relax with
only a few hours left and one more tick
on my notes I hopped on the train to
Queens there's a lot to see over there
Flushing Meadows with its Unisphere and
observation towers are both in the game
so too is Terminal 5 of JFK Airport but
I ate just one more place I wanted to
hit once I made my way over to Duke's
the Steinway beer garden location for
many great data in GTA 4 it's based on a
real-world beer garden located just off
Steinway Street in a story of Queens
the Bohemian beer garden is the oldest
beer garden in the city dating back to
the early 1900s drinking alone at the
end of a long day is a little bit sad so
I called up another friend to go on a
date Weiss gaming's Austin Walker who
was more than happy to share some piss
water with a tired sweaty Irish tourist
you want that you want that beer
roll some beer
be great this is the worst ever
so what to say about my 12 hours in
Liberty City in many ways it was exactly
as I remembered it colorful varied
seemingly endless sure there were a lot
more tourists and it took longer to get
everywhere and yet it smelled a bit
weird but New York City in a very real
way will always be Liberty City to me
and above all that this trip has
reminded me of just how far video games
have come in creating incredible vibrant
realistic virtual worlds thanks for
watching the points to keep up to date
on my latest adventure feel free to
follow me on Twitter and for continuing
coverage of video games both real and
virtual stay tuned to Kingsport comm see
you around
[Music]
you